we have never had a century without
great power conflict of some kind
a superpower war would be a type of
conflict we haven't seen since the
second world war and it would be
dramatically different any nuclear
missile
launched from cuba against any nation in
the western hemisphere as an attack
by the soviet union on the united states
direct conflict between the soviet union
and the us thankfully never materialized
and china is the only country equipped
to challenge the us as a superpower it
has the motivation and the means to do
so with a huge economy it can bring to
bear absolutely this is a risk that
should be taken very seriously
so what would a u.s china war look like
and is conflict inevitable
centuries ago china built this great war
to defend its borders and in recent
decades they've made other moves to
protect and expand their territory and
influence leading to an explosive rise
in power
since 1978 when china began to open up
its economy in the wake of chairman
mao's death
gdp has risen an average of roughly 10
percent every year
it's gone from an estimated
149.5 billion us dollars in 78 to a
massive 17.7 trillion in 2021.
800 million people have escaped poverty
in the country that's about 10 percent
of the world's population that
incredible economic growth essentially
tethered china to global supply chains
spanning the world and that created
heavy trade dependencies and with that
vulnerabilities
this economic rise has stalled slightly
in recent years but china remains on
course to become the biggest economy in
the world sometime in the next decade
the leadership in beijing has also been
on a mission to use that economic growth
to transform its military power china
thinks that
now it's time for china to make use of
its
greater power to actually defend its
land claimed territories it's widely
thought that china is the world's second
biggest spender on its military behind
the united states
but a lack of transparency over that
spending makes it difficult to prove
the country is thought to be upping its
nuclear weapons stockpile developing
highly dangerous hypersonic missiles and
is already a world leader in cyber
warfare
historically china has been a land power
but over the last decades it's created a
modern navy from scratch most of it
based in hainan
it now has more vessels than any other
country and those warships have been
built to protect their interests and
project power beyond these waters but
they are untested
president xi jinping has made no secret
of his military ambitions
he wants china to have a world-class
military and one that can be fighting
and winning wars by 2049.
china has an increasingly concentrated
power system domestically
where
the power is mostly concentrate
concentrated under one person china's
paramount leader
so this sense of urgency comes directly
from the top leadership and now under
china's environment there is no one who
is able to stand in his way
that makes it much harder to predict
china's decision the us has the biggest
military the biggest economy and is
arguably the most influential nation in
the world but china is catching up
challenging u.s supremacy and some in
america do not like it
putting constant pressure on
china we can't continue to allow
china to rape our country and that's
what they're doing competition with
china is going to be stiff
there have been frictions between the
countries for decades of course with
international incidents breaking out of
the 95 to 96 third taiwan straight
crisis the 1999 bombing of the chinese
embassy by the u.s in belgrade
and the 2001 heinen's spy plane incident
but china's rise means it's now on a
more even footing with the us with both
countries vying to lead the world
incidents between them could be more
likely to escalate into a major war
neither side us or china is explicitly
seeking conflict especially when we're
talking about the two biggest economies
in the world throwing down essentially
causing massive collateral damage in the
world
but the political economic security
technological societal historical forces
all of these are converging
to reach this point of intense
competition
so how could one break out
this is the most likely place for any
conflict to break out taiwan
the small island off the southeast coast
of china split from the mainland after
the communist revolution in 1949.
taiwan is self-run and democratic but
it's also of key strategic importance to
the u.s and to china the ruling party
seems to believe that taiwan is also
related to its domestic legitimacy so
it's hugely important to the ruling
party
the stake is also very high for the
united states
if taiwan is lost there is a concern
that
china might use taiwan
to
launch further into west pacific
and the u.s credibility could be
undermined if u.s doesn't come to
taiwan's defense
recently president joe biden has
reinforced america's commitment to the
island are you willing to get involved
militarily to defend taiwan if it comes
to that yes
you are
that's the commitment we made but
beijing has long wanted to control
taiwan with xi going so far as to say
that reunification must be fulfilled and
he hasn't ruled out military force to
achieve this
please rise ladies and gentlemen the
president and the speaker have arrived
in august 2022 a trip by u.s house
speaker nancy pelosi to taiwan sparked
one of the biggest escalations in
tension for years
and now more than ever
america's solidarity with taiwan is
crucial and that is the message we are
bringing here today
china significantly upped military
drills around the island leading to
fears it could develop into full scale
foundation
foreign
the war games eventually wound down but
it was a clear example of how fragile
the situation over taiwan is
china is more or less secure in its land
borders it has weaker neighbors and a
vast army at sea it's different it's
surrounded by a string of democracies
with powerful militaries like japan
south korea and australia and further
out beyond that in the south china sea
there are a host of countries with their
own claims their own interests to defend
the south china sea is vital to china
the country is a net importer of energy
and food so control over the waterways
could be a matter of survival it needs
to keep those roots open it isn't just
about warships though china has
pioneered a blurring of operations with
the navy the coast guard and the
maritime militia a fleet of fishing
boats some of their mom add all of them
up together and you get a lot more
capability especially when it comes to
transporting a large number of troops
for an invasion hainan is where many
chinese missions would begin but their
aim would be far beyond these immediate
waters the spratly islands a small
militarized reef the china says is an
inviolable part of its territory are
1500 kilometers from here and likely to
be a flashpoint china has this
long-standing position
that it
has
territorial sovereignty over those
islands
so it is hard for china to make a
compromise
and china has already taken measures to
strengthen and
enhance
those
military
installations on the islands
china is a huge country with plenty of
interest to defend so there are a lot of
potential areas for conflict like here
in the east china sea where there are
contested areas with their old rival
japan another key us ally
or here another flare-up on the
china-india border and how developing
technologies could make a conflict over
the himalayan border possible china's
rivals know there could be a war on the
horizon and they're teaming up there is
the quadrilateral security dialogue
known as the quad an alliance between
the us japan india and australia that
was resurrected in 2017. then the orcas
pact signed at the end of 2021 between
the us uk and australia to address the
issues in the south china sea
it's three very like-minded allies
standing shoulder to shoulder china was
particularly annoyed by this one calling
it irresponsible and showing an obsolete
cold war mentality they are making some
progress they are
building stronger
defense ties they are working together
to develop high-tech military
technologies there is a long way to go
before the alliances like august to
develop the necessary
military hardware and soft skills to
actually fight china in the future war
so if the worst did happen and one of
those flash points escalated into
all-out war between china and the us how
all-encompassing would that be i think
it's going to start small but a small
war under current circumstances could
escalate very quickly
if we're talking about an all-out war
it is it can escalate all the way to an
all-out nuclear exchange between the two
major powers everything will be
destroyed in that scenario both sides
will result to economic
sanctions
and political coercion they will rally
their own allied
countries and friendly countries to
support support them at the u.n and
other international platforms
the world will be divided for sure and
it's hard to imagine the boundary of
that type of conflict the idea of the
fucilities trap states that when a
rising power threatens to overtake a
ruling power war always follows
thucydides was an ancient greek
historian was writing about the rise of
athens and the fear that instilled in
sparta
if he is around today he may well
substitute athens for china and sparta
for the united states the us remember
hasn't really had to worry about a
challenger to u.s primacy in global sea
power tech space in a very long time
and the us is profoundly uncomfortable
with that reality from china's
perspective the reason there is growing
trouble between china united states is
because china is rising and china's rise
is gradually challenging the
predominance
of western countries in international
system
throughout history rival powers have
often come into conflict but none of
those have the weapons of mass
destruction we have now the russian
invasion of ukraine has shown that the
type of wars we thought were left in the
past are still possible
it's surprising to see
a military actually invade another
country um violate its sovereignty in
such a brutal manner risk
such economic collateral damage
but
geopolitical insecurities can lead you
to do
um some some very extreme things and so
i think that's very important then to
apply that lens to how we examine china
but when it comes to war between nuclear
states nothing is inevitable
we need to discard cold war mentality
and seek peaceful coexistence and
win-win outcomes what we can be sure of
is that the rivalry between china and
the us will be the defining one of our
time whether it remains a cold war
or turns hot
it would be a conflict the likes of
which the world has never seen and
hopefully will not but both sides are
boring from an ancient roman phrase if
you want peace prepare for war